soit c'est facile de parler au micro de
parler à la radio de parler à la
télévision de savoir qui a trois ou
quatre continents qui vous regardent 27
pays en afrique
mais parler ici au tedx à grand bassam
c'est quelque chose de particulier c'est
quelque chose de particulier parce que
finalement on se livre pas simplement
nous les orateurs et oratrice mais on se
livre une partie de nous-mêmes on donne
de soi on donne de ce que l'on est
je m'appelle robert assène jean beati
d'orb razengues à moynat tata brazza
mois dans la ville et c'est celui-là
c'est celui-là c'est ce jeune garçon
très souriant comme vous le voyez à ces
bagarreurs boudeur avec un peu plus de
cheveux à l'époque mais qui avait déjà
un esprit et des idées bien trempé
c'est celui qui naît dans une fratrie de
huit frères et soeurs dans un quartier
qui s'appelle bas congo à brazzaville
sur l'avenue de brazza dans ce fief qui
m'a vu naître dans suis très fier alary
du pool fils d'un fils lui-même de chefs
de village et d'une infirmière diplômée
d'état comme on disait à l'époque est à
cette époque dans ce congo des années de
braise
on se demandait toujours toiture le
numéro combien sur le premier et le
deuxième puis le troisième match le 6e
et chez nous quand on sait pas forcément
l'énoncé pression non un tel non non non
tanguay c'est à dire toi bon vient le
numéro 6 en l'occurrence moi même et je
sais pas pour vous mais moi j'ai
toujours eu ce regard très particulier
très affectueux par rapport à nos papas
quand j n'ont pas pas c'est pas
simplement le papa de la maison mais
c'est tout c'est tonton tout ce qu'ils
sont là qui gravitent
qu'on regarde vraiment comme des figures
qui sont invincibles qui ont des rêves
plein la tête et dont on se demande
toujours si on va pouvoir un jour les
égaler ou se rapprocher même de ce
qu'ils ont fait comme expérience dans ce
conte god de l'époque qui sort d
indépendance et dont il nous reste des
photos en noir et blanc on sent la joie
sans enthousiasme on sont les espoirs on
sent la discipline en sont aussi quelque
part les rêves les rêves avec ces gens
qui vont construire cette afrique
cette afrique qui va devenir
indépendante mon papa brazeau ganda jean
pascal était de ses enfants du village
qui alla à pied à l'école
et puis qui aimait nous raconter une
fois qu'on était conscient vous savez
moi j'ai croisé fulbert youlou la baie
j'ai vu les os x et j'ai vu ces figures
de l'indépendance
j'ai rêvé des gens comme patrice
aimerait le monde a et ça c'est un sacré
défi parce que tout de suite on se dit
mais - qu'est-ce que je vais faire
il faut que j'essaie au moins de leur
arrivée au moins la cheville faut que
j'essaie quand même avec des grands
frères qui sont la très charismatique
des grands du quartier de joue aussi ma
petite partition mais cette petite
partition on sait jamais d'où elle vient
on va à l'école parce qu'il faut faire
plaisir aux parents on essaie d'avoir
les meilleures notes possibles pour leur
faire plaisir pour gagner des beignets
pour gagner peut-être des arachides et
surtout pour pas avoir la chicotte
mais on sait pas où on veut arriver et
puis à ce moment là on se dit il faut
quand même que moi je me distingue alors
là des années passant une fois que le
collège a été validée une fois qu'on
s'est planté au bac une première fois
alors que son frère qui est juste avant
soit la u on se dit bon ok on va les
étudier
on va étudier on arrive dans un fief qui
est le village de plus étrange d'afrique
qui s'appelle paris
et à paris il faut rivaliser
d'ingéniosité il faut se démarquer
on est là dans les cités les campus on
est dans les appartements qu'on partage
en commun même parfois dans des squats
oui des squats rogner parce que personne
ne veut payer son loyer tout seul et
puis on se cherche on est dense ont
cherché lit comme on dit en côte
d'ivoire et on s'illustre comme on peut
et surtout en bringue ce qu'on a une
bonne assurance vie 1
on va en boîte de nuit les grands frères
régleront les factures labour ciel passe
tant mieux si elle passe pas tant pis
les aînés vont gérer et puis on commence
à se poser des questions parce qu'on dit
mais finalement toi tu deviens quoi et
tu fais quoi
et c'est une période qui est très
étrange un questionnement par lequel on
passe parce que certes il ya les bancs
de l'université nancy toujours il faut
être agronome ingénieurs comme le vieux
il faut être peut-être un médecin comme
peut-être le dr karaboué qui ont pu tuer
le colonel il faut être quelqu'un qui a
le charisme pour devenir avocat parce
que ce sont des professions qui font
bien on est avocat on est juriste extra
cas président lançait pas là bas que ça
va se dérouler déjà il faut veiller tard
il faut étudier il faut avoir des gros
cahier ça ça va pas quand on arrive dans
paris à des coins où finalement se
retrouve presque sommes au quartier à
bas congo alors je sais pas moi marcory
peut-être amato nez ou ailleurs et ce
qui est non plus et que l'on bringue et
les gens que l'on voit à côté nous avec
qui on bringue eux ils passent à la télé
ce moment là on se dit dans mais quand
même ça c'est pas mal tu vas là il ya
telle grande hotte l artisanat monnaie
et la zone là dans la bio et à saumon
stade et report des habits bien on voit
aurlus on voit un fils de ce fief
d'ailleurs le seul mais un certain
frédéric ehui et qui arrive qu'il dit
mais toi tu travailles pas tu es
toujours là je te vois tu es dans les
soirées du brun enfin on en vient peu à
qu'une magie sans faire de pub de ce
genre d'occasion et puis le temps
passant ce 10 mai et si finalement
j'allais fouillé par la ja les fouilles
et de ce côté là à la maison on écouté
énormément nui
mon père ta fin mélomane il se lève il
écoute des classiques comme vous pouvait
on imaginer et franklin boukaka grands
musiciens congolais
il écoute les francos on écoute mario en
danse la rumba je pourrais pas faire la
démonstration parce que sinon à les
sortir de la salle et puis on commence à
voir dans l'histoire de ces
personnalités qui sont un petit peu des
gens qui habitent dans notre propre
maison
des guides des formateurs alors c'est
vrai qu'au moment où loin beau chante
mario et au moment où les quais jazz
vraiment va à la conquête du monde
entier en dollar et de l'afrique non
adolescents on est très jeune mais on se
rend compte quand même que ces
personnalités africaines qui
représentent déjà des modèles quelque
part et des valeurs pour nous elles
peuvent avoir une incidence sur notre
parcours et surtout quand on parle des
femmes et du message qu'elle donne il ya
les abêti masikini aller bella bello et
puis une femme qui se coiffe disons
comme maman maman limite de temps en
temps on voit ma main makeba et puis on
se dit tiens finalement cette maman
makeba et ma mère raison quelque chose
de commun c'est que elles sont fières
elle porte cette africanité
elles portent finalement cette identité
et on prend conscience que même en étant
en europe
cette afrique elle a beaucoup de choses
à nous apporter et c'est à ce moment que
je me suis dit la musique comme bagage
intellectuel une certaine structuration
au niveau de l'esprit parce qu on a fait
des cours on s'est assis à la faculté
est ce que tout ça je pourrais pas faire
un magma qui nous amènerait quelque part
parce qu'entre temps il faut dire que
les résultats sont pas au rendez-vous
aussi le bonhomme va vers une faculté il
apparaît 8 à saint-denis faculté à ces
révolutionnaires on trouve vraiment des
cas et des frères qui sont là qui eux
aussi rêvent qu'ils savent pas ce qu'ils
vont faire un malamine koné tient
d'imagés créer une marque de fringues de
vêtements je vais faire des baskets
pense pas encore à airness à joseph
andjou qui met une veste bleue qui va
sur les plateaux de télé qui sait même
pas qui un jour et sera rédacteur
peut-être d'une émission ici un an à la
télévision ivoirienne
et on se dit je vais existe à ma manière
et je vais essayer d'aller en free lance
dans une sorte de masterclass alors à ce
moment là je me balade je vais partout
je prends le train je fraude le train
pour être plus précis lyon nantes
bordeaux et je rencontre
cette afrique qui est celle que jeunes à
travers des frères des soeurs qui
viennent du mali qui viennent de la
centrafrique qui viennent du tchad
ça devient une sorte de master class qui
pour moi est d'ailleurs moins embêtante
que l'école parce que non seulement je
n'ai pas à me lever tôt et en plus j'ai
toujours la garantie des aînés qui me
donne un peu de sou qui me supra comme
on dirait ici donc c'est plutôt bien en
plus les amendes arrive chez eux et je
me dis là il ya quelque chose à faire
c'est à dire je prends mon temps et je
vogue sans forcément dire qu'un jour
peut-être je me retrouverais derrière un
micro quelque part et cette période elle
est très particulière parce qu'au même
moment est un type qui a un incroyable
qu'on voit beaucoup à la télé qui a
changé de visage pas mal de fois et dont
on a vu les clips et donne la pochette
de disque était constamment sur le
meuble du grand frère et je me dis mais
attendez ce gars-là c'est incroyable il
passe à la télé il laisse happer ils
vont des millions de disques et aurec
des lamas et d'un serpent on lui demande
même pas de compte et les superstars à
travers le monde et en fouillant plus
loin je me dis tiens ce bonhomme c'est
quand même un personnage assez
incroyable alors il n'en reste plus
beaucoup mais à l'époque je me dis je
laisse pousser les cheveux je garde la
veste blanche
voilà ce type c'est michael jackson
sacré michael quand même j'ai envie dire
à la jeune génération qui tu es j'ai
envie de demander à ceux qui étaient
déjà là avec des cheveux peut-être comme
le lieutenant-colonel ou peut être comme
le doyen demander qui n'a pas essayé de
faire le moonwalk or essaie de se
rapprocher de michael ceux qui ont
essayé de le faire me lever la main ce
cas pour ma part je les fais et ce
moment-là je me dis il ya l'afrique mais
également le reste du monde alors on
écoute de la musique on écoute tout ce
qui passe de la fin de la même manière
qu'on écoute le roomba la rumba le matin
on écoute de la new wave et puis on se
dit tiens c'est quand même pas mal parce
que ces bonhommes chante en anglais donc
je vais me perfectionner aussi et tout
ça me donne des outils d'une sorte de
culture qui est une culture mondiale
on réfléchit pas mais on avance on ouvre
des bouquins on se cultive
on essaie de gratter un peu plus loin
que la surface et que la notoriété que
ces personnes on est au fur et à mesure
du temps on se rend bien compte qu'il ya
des gens qui sont plus importants que
d'autres
et ces personnes sur notre parcours et
dans cette période particulière que j'ai
pu grâce à fatou et grâce à en déca que
je vous demande d'applaudir que je
remercie du télex mettre en avant parce
que ce sont des gens qui sont pour moi
des fondements de ce que j'appelle la
préhistoire ce monsieur
c est un papa c'est le premier cinéaste
congolais s'appelle sébastien kamba il
travaille à la télévision mais
légalement cinéastes et réalisateurs
dans ces années 90 comme vous le savez
l'afrique est en mouvement et ce
monsieur a réalisé des films comme ceux
sur la conférence nationale dont on
parlait beaucoup à jean il me dit toi tu
as une voix les très agité et une danse
tu t'habilles voilà tu rêves d'amérique
mais tu as quelque chose de particulier
via un petit peu il me donne un texte et
me demande de lire
il fait la même chose pour des personnes
qui sont autour et le lendemain vient me
voir et me dit nous allons partir dans
un studio et tu va enregistrer sa voix
et tu vas être le commentateur de ce
film qui s'appellera la conférence
nationale souveraine au congo
[Applaudissements]
et voilà comment sans être passé par une
école de journalisme sans avoir fait
forcément le parcours que beaucoup de
mes pairs et mes aînés ont pu faire je
me retrouve dans les arcanes de cette
profession des médias il m'en apprend
les rudiments il m'en apprend les règles
il m'apprend à poser une diction mais
surtout à écouter et il me donne une
sorte de sauf conduits en me disant tu
es armée avec la voix mais la voix ça
suffit pas il faut travailler et le
travail quand tu te balades un coin un
autre de la france à l'époque ça veut
dire au milieu des années 90 se
retrouver du côté de nantes en france
dans la côte ouest
et là je vais croiser un grand frère qui
s'appelle qu'à lomé boto à mon goût qui
est un grand frère qui me dit tu sais
c'est bien de s'exprimer c'est bien
d'avoir du débit mais il faut à des
planchers et ce monsieur va me mettre
derrière un micro de manière pérenne un
micro que je ne quitterai plus qui sera
celui d'une radio jet fm à nantes est de
96 à 99 nous allons essayer d'entretenir
les uns et les autres sur la culture sur
la politique sur les activités d
actualité et un beau jour je reçois un
coup de fil qui émane de paris nina
karine mono une des animatrices d'africa
numéro un est enceinte et hawk élevé il
fallait la remplacer georges courrèges
directeur du centre culturel français
d'abidjan à l'époque
la côte d'ivoire déjà cette époque la
map el himdi congé maternité trois mois
pour nina tu peut la remplacer
3 - en 99 1 en 2000 vous continuez vous
calculez et 18 ans de quotidienne sur
une radio panafricaine et internationale
le résultat de cette aventure est le
résultat de ce que je suis c'est d'abord
une conjugaison de circonstances mais
c'est une conjugaison de bienveillance
on ne sait jamais les personnes qui sont
en face de nous on ne sait jamais ce
qu'elles vont nous apprendre et on le
soit encore moins quand on se retrouve
tout à coup face à une lumière face à
une notoriété qu'on n'imaginait même pas
au départ les parents sont rassurés
parce qu'il tourne le bouton et peuvent
vous écoute à brazzaville ailleurs et se
disent tiens ce petit là finalement il
en train de devenir quelqu'un
le rêve est une chose importante le
réveil oui mais l'abnégation
l'abnégation c'est aussi un choix c'est
celui de décider de vivre à 19 septembre
1989 un vol qui n'atterrira jamais au
dessus du tonique du ténéré un avion
celui du dc 10 d'uta qui explose en
plein vol dans lequel figuraient gérard
christian vincent
mes frères et un tournant qui est celui
de se dire il faut se relever il faut
avancer on était une bande de quatre et
du lendemain jour au lendemain je me
retrouve seul et c'est à ce moment là
j'ai prêté serment avec moi même j'ai
décidé de vivre vivre ça veut dire aller
en face de l'adversité et même quand ce
genre de coups moutons sur la tête
regardez toujours ce qu'il ya de
meilleur d'où le surnom de captain
sourire que certains m'ont donné à
l'écran mais parfois l'adversité est
très têtu
et elle nous amène des choses positives
et les choses positives ce sont des
rencontres comme celle d'un monsieur
toujours dans le cadre de la radio qui a
un jour parce que je reçois parce qu'il
a une actualité et ce monsieur je le
regarde je me dis non c'est quand même
pas lui finalement c'est lui c'est celui
que j'appelle pam à nous qui nous dit
bongo en l'occurrence et qui au delà de
tout ce qu'il peut représenter est
d'abord une personne qui dit tu sais moi
comment j'ai fait carrière et je dis
j'ose même pas imaginer
il me dit je me suis toujours mis
derrière la musique et j'ai toujours mis
la musique devant si tu as une passion
dans l'existence
et si un fondement que tu dois retenir
c'est toujours de te mettre derrière les
autres d'écouter d'apprendre cette leçon
de vie c'est une leçon que je pratique
au quotidien et que j'ai eu à garder il
ya celle est en moi à un moment qui a
été encore plus particulier il y a 6 ans
aujourd'hui c'est ce moment où on se
demande si les choses vont basculer
complètement si elles vont s'arrêter net
du jour au lendemain aussi avant se
poursuivre cette vie elle est faite de
hauts et de bas aller chercher dans
cette préhistoire dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui ce qui va vous rendre plus
fort et je vous garantis que à ce moment
là elle se révélera avoue d'une autre
manière aux nomades juillet 2013
il fait très chaud à paris pourtant moi
j'ai très froid je sens que je ne suis
pas forcément bien je prends rendez vous
chez un médecin et je m'en souviendrai
toujours
c'est un mercredi faisait beau le
médecin dit écoutez vous êtes seul je
dis oui je suis seul il m'a dit y a
personne qui peut venir pour vous
retrouver gênant on écoute et on est
ensemble et voilà vous pouvez me dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont designer
d'être un bon vivant en fait un métier
voiliers du monde etc
vous allez peut-être vous arrêter
pendant quelques temps et à ce moment-là
il prononce un mot qui est terrible dans
l'esprit de beaucoup d'entre nous
prononce le mot cancer et me dit
monsieur brazza vous êtes attendant
lymphome c'est une forme de cancer du
sang alors je le redis
je lui dis d'accord et me dis qu'est ce
qu'on fait je lui dis voulait toujours
que je continue à vous en parler là je
dis non non stop j'ai appelé mon grand
frère pas pour payer mes factures ce
coup ci mais il faut que ce soit à côté
de moi il me retrouve
on est face à lui et nous explique
finalement que cette maladie qui est une
forme de cancer et c'est pour ça que
j'ai écouté attentivement ce que rosine
vieyra leur qui tombent chez n'importe
qui les enfants les grands les vieux les
vielles les messieurs enfin bref est une
forme de concerts qui est très
particulière mais qu'on peut soigner il
me dit vous savez quand vous avez un
rhume vous soigner ça fait mal à la tête
vous prenez une aspirine
quand vous avez un cancer en fait de la
chimiothérapie est-ce que vous êtes
prêts on est à mercredi
le samedi la chimiothérapie commençait
2013 2014
et puis un matin un médecin qui vous dit
ça y est vous êtes en rémission
toujours cette idée de se servir de ce
que la vie nous donne pour mieux avancer
toujours cette préhistoire dans laquelle
on va chercher de la force avec des
parents aimants avec une famille aimante
une famille qui des fois n'a même pas
besoin de vous parlez pour vous
signifier son amour la présence cette
présence bienveillante
celle qui fait que même quand vous êtes
en aplasie en auto greffes et vous savez
même pas où êtes vous sentez les mains
d'une personne et vous devez les yeux et
cette personne c'est votre mère et qui
vous regardent et qui à ce moment-là
vous dit ça va aller et puis on va
avancer
c'est le résultat de ce que je suis
aujourd'hui cet amour de ses proches
d'un jour comme vous de ses proches de
toujours qui sont peut-être pas là
matériellement dans cette salle
aujourd'hui du télex à grand bassam
mais qui m'ont appris que finalement
être auprès des autres êtres avec les
autres c'est certainement le meilleur
médicament alors le médicament soit
aussi de trouver de la motivation on
peut la trouver à la télévision parce
que toujours dans ce parcours qui nous
offre parfois de la chance
après sébastien kamba après qu'à lomé
boto amont où on tombe sur les gens qui
vous disent ils donc
la télé ça dit oui on l'a déjà fait non
en 2010 + d'afrique
la ligue des champions talents d'afrique
et un matin ma soeur et léa sourds qui
vole vers d'autres aventures
ça diraient de faire le plateau de
réussite et à ce moment là j oui j'ai
pas les connaissances éminente du maire
de semoule au pot j'ai pas la dextérité
et le charisme en termes d'entretien du
préfet reims au toby guerrier ou encore
la combativité comme entrepreneuse de
sarah mais je me dis on va tenter le
coup et grâce à vous grâce à ce que vous
m'apportez chaque jour à travers des
clins d'oeil
les bons jours dans une rue ou sur les
réseaux sociaux on se construit et en
avance cette expérience de la pré
histoire
elle construit aujourd'hui elle
construira demain et à ce moment là on a
juste envie de dire dès que les choses
sont belles et que dieu fasse qu'elle
soit encore plus belle demain et comme
je dis souvent sur des postes quand vous
lisez sur internet
il ya un mot qui résume tout c'est que
de l'arrêt dit et peut sortir cette
plante
cette plante c'est la vie c'est ce qui
n'est pas encore et ce sur quoi et en
quoi on doit espérer
et une fois qu'on l'espère on est déjà
franchi un grand pas et quand ce palais
est franchie on peut juste se retourner
vers le très haut pour ceux qui ont un
peu cheap et réalité vers vous autres et
puis il se dire et vous dire ma tondo
qui chez moi qu'on veut dire merci
[Applaudissements]